Trascrizione: Giulio Bernasconi
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Signori e signore,
l'Intelligenza Artificiale non esiste!
Questa è una provocazione che voglio farvi
per farvi pensare
al fatto che, probabilmente,
per come vi è stata sempre raccontata,
o come la potete esperire nel mondo
sembra questa cosa magica,
che si auto-crea, che si auto-determina.
In realtà, non è così.
E cerco di raccontarvelo
attraverso la mia esperienza
di vita e professionale
e come sono arrivata a questa conclusione.
L'uomo ha sempre voluto
superare i propri limiti:
dominare gli elementi, il fuoco,
voler muoversi nel mondo,
voler esplorare, voler andare sulla luna,
e ci siamo arrivati! Ok?
E l'ultima delle sfide
è proprio comprendere
il proprio intelletto,
la propria intelligenza,
E allora, da ex neuroscienziata,
che ha voluto intraprendere
questo percorso di sfida
nella comprensione di uno degli organi
più meravigliosi e complessi che abbiamo
si è fatta questa domanda,
ad un certo punto,
dopo quasi nove anni
di ricerca sul cervello.
C'è un paradosso,
dietro questa volontà dell'uomo
di capire e di riprodurre l'intelligenza
che abbiamo dentro una macchina.
E cioè, come è possibile
capire il cervello,
analizzarlo, scomporlo e ricomporlo,
usando lo stesso strumento?
Come possiamo astrarci da fuori,
ed oggettivamente analizzare uno strumento
che stiamo utilizzando
per fare la stessa cosa?
E allora vi porto
in un percorso di analisi
di come l'intelligenza umana
si è sviluppata nella storia
e come si è sviluppata
anche quella artificiale,
e dei parallelismi che troveremo insieme.
Allora, Yuval Harari,
in un libro bellissimo, "Sapiens",
definisce l'evoluzione
della cognizione umana
come una rivoluzione.
Questa è stata una rivoluzione,
se pensate che l'intelligenza umana
per come la conosciamo
si è sviluppata in un tempo
veramente molto breve
rispetto a tutta l'evoluzione dell'uomo.
Solo negli ultimi 50.000 anni
abbiamo sviluppato una serie
di facoltà cognitive
che oggi ci portano
ad essere quello che siamo.
La prima pietra miliare
nello sviluppo cognitivo
è quella dello sviluppo
della corteccia prefrontale
che è un po' quella che ci differenzia
dai nostri cugini primati,
che ha permesso di osservare il mondo,
selezionarlo attentivamente
e risolvere i problemi complessi.
Dopo abbiamo avuto la necessità
di esprimere questi concetti,
questa complessità che si era creata
nel nostro cervello,
e abbiamo cominciato a parlare,
quindi ad esplorare la dimensione
un po' più metaforica del nostro pensiero
che doveva essere espressa
attraverso il linguaggio;
e poi l'abbiamo voluto scrivere,
quindi, per tramandarlo,
per poterlo far insegnare,
per poterlo divulgare nel mondo.
Fino a poi voler creare
delle connessioni fra queste conoscenze
e cominciare a capire e a rappresentare
questi concetti nel nostro cervello,
per poi avere la capacità
critica di manipolarli.
Fino a creare una conoscenza collettiva
che poi con il web e la tecnologia
si è espansa incredibilmente.
Invece, la storia dell'evoluzione
dell'Intelligenza Artificiale
non è proprio così lineare.
Sicuramente esponenziale,
ad un certo punto della sua storia,
come quella dell'intelligenza umana;
ma ha avuto dei problemi.
In realtà, l'Intelligenza Artificiale,
o i principi dell'IA,
esistono da tanti anni:
dal 1950, più o meno,
con Touring che postula
il suo test, l"Imitation Game";
e da lì si è cominciato
ad esplorare questa materia
e ci sono stati degli investimenti.
Però, ad un certo punto
siamo caduti in un'era di cupezza.
La chiamiamo l'"inverno"
dell'Intelligenza Artificiale.
Questo perché non c'erano abbastanza dati,
e quindi non era possibile generalizzare
i modelli di machine learning
attraverso i dati.
I dati sono ciò che viene dato
ad una macchina per imparare.
Quindi senza dati non si riusciva
a farli esponenzialmente crescere.
Quindi si son perse le speranze,
l'interesse e anche gli investimenti.
Ma poi è successo
un qualcosa di incredibile.
Ci si è accorti, ad un certo punto,
che eravamo in condizioni
di avere tanti, tanti dati
che sono stati collezionati
negli ultimi 50 anni
e quindi c'è stato un esponenziale
sviluppo di queste tecnologie
che solo negli ultimi dieci anni
sono ciò che voi conoscete ad oggi.
E quindi, quali sono gli elementi veri
che ci aiutano a far sviluppare
questa tecnologia?
Sono principalmente tre:
i big data, quindi tanti dati,
tantissimi dati collezionati ovunque,
sia da oggetti come il vostro cellulare,
che avete sicuramente in tasca,
che raccoglie trilioni
di dati, ogni giorno,
su di voi, su dove vi muovete;
all'Internet delle cose, quindi le cose
che catturano dati anche loro.
Un altro elemento
è sicuramente il cloud computing,
quindi la potenza
computazionale del cloud.
E adesso stiamo sviluppando
il quantum computing,
che è ancora più veloce nel processamento.
E questi due elementi hanno reso possibile
lo sviluppo di modelli
di machine learning e di IA molto potenti.
E allora, su questo tema
vi faccio un parallelismo
tra come il bambino impara
a vedere il mondo
e come una macchina potrebbe imparare
a riconoscere le immagini.
Un bambino, da quando nasce,
ovviamente senza ricevere
nessuna indicazione
e nessuna regola su come
deve percepire il mondo,
impiega più o meno sei mesi
prima di poter vedere i contorni,
i colori e le immagini.
Se invece viene dato ad un algoritmo
di riconoscimento visivo,
un poco più di un milione di immagini
per imparare a riconoscerle,
questo algoritmo impiega
circa due o tre giorni
per poter riconoscere un'immagine
esattamente come un uomo.
Quindi, da sei mesi che un bambino impiega
per creare delle connessioni
nella sua corteccia occipitale
e poter vedere il mondo,
a tre giorni di un algoritmo.
Questa cosa spaventa qualcuno.
Uno degli esponenti più importanti,
a mio avviso, di questa disciplina
è Andrew Ng, che ha lavorato in Google,
ed è il fondatore di Cloudera,
e dice che qualsiasi cosa
che può essere processata
dal pensiero umano
in meno di un secondo,
probabilmente può essere automatizzata.
Guardiamo quindi le conquiste
di questa disciplina nella storia.
Il primo caso, l'algoritmo
di IBM Deep Blue,
ha battuto il campione mondiale
mai battuto nella storia, Kasparov,
nel gioco degli scacchi.
che è uno dei giochi più complessi
di problem solving che noi conosciamo.
Qualche anno dopo, nel 2016,
Google col suo AlphaGo
sfida il campione mondiale di [Go],
che è un gioco - lo possiamo immaginare
come il gioco degli scacchi al cubo.
Per cui, le combinazioni di questo gioco,
le possibili combinazioni
sono più grandi di tutte le particelle
e gli atomi dell'universo.
E un giocatore di Go
impiega circa dieci anni
per padroneggiare questo gioco.
Ecco: questo algoritmo,
nel giro di tre giorni,
osservando le partite giocate dall'uomo,
e poi giocando contro se stesso,
è riuscito a battere
questo campione mondiale
e ricorderete probabilmente
la [rassegna] stampa
in cui questo giocatore cinese
era assolutamente basito,
non riusciva a capire
come fosse possibile.
Qualche anno dopo,
con Microsoft, nel 2016,
siamo arrivati alla possibilità
di riconoscere le immagini
e ad arrivare alla parità con l'uomo
nel riconoscimento di immagini.
Vi faccio un esempio,
per me eticamente molto bello,
nella diagnosi del cancro:
se un medico ha un accuratezza
del 90 - 95 percento
nel riconoscimento di cellule tumorali,
grazie all'aiuto di un algoritmo
di riconoscimento visivo
che ovviamente
ha imparato ed ha osservato
tantissimi vetrini di cellule cancerogene:
ecco, la combinazione
delle due conoscenze, delle due abilità
porta ad una accuratezza del 99 percento.
È interessante, comunque,
che l'uomo è più bravo
a individuare i falsi positivi
mentre la macchina è più brava
a identificare piccole differenze
percettive dell'immagine.
Un pochino più avanti,
siamo arrivati alla possibilità
di comprendere il linguaggio.
Quindi tutti i vostri device voice,
come Alexa, Google o Cortana
sono sicuramente
un esperimento interessante
che tutti noi stiamo utilizzando.
Un'altra grossa conquista:
nel 2017, con Microsoft,
si è fatto un esperimento.
Si sono dati 500 articoli di Wikipedia
a una macchina e a una serie di umani
e le si è fatto un test
usando un test standardizzato
della University of Stanford,
e le si sono fatte delle domande.
La macchina e l'uomo hanno risposto
esattamente nello stesso modo.
E infine,
la capacità di traduzione
in simultanea in 15 lingue
del cinese, che è una delle lingue
più difficili da imparare:
i bambini cinesi imparano
a parlare completamente
dopo circa dieci anni,
al contrario dei bambini occidentali
che ce ne mettono cinque.
Ma allora,
che cos'è che veramente
ci differenzia dalla macchina?
Perché ho introdotto l'argomento
dicendo che non esiste
l'Intelligenza Artificiale?
Non esiste nella misura
in cui la vogliamo pensare
come un sistema che possa analizzare
dei problemi complessi.
Allora facciamo il paragone
con la scala causale di Judea Pearl,
che ha scritto un libro bellissimo
chiamato "The book of why".
che analizza il modo
in cui l'essere umano impara
e lo parallelizza verso la macchina.
Immaginate un bambino che impara il mondo,
e sta scalando questa scala.
Prima di tutto comincerà
ad associare degli elementi:
se faccio A, succede B:
come A influenza B.
Dopodiché si comincia ad associare
sempre di più degli elementi,
e si comincia anche
ad esperirli nel mondo,
e quindi si agisce nel mondo.
E questo è il pensiero
un po' più fattuale,
un pensiero un pochino più complicato.
Si riesce a capire come il nostro corpo,
e il nostro essere nel mondo,
possa produrre degli effetti,
e come questi effetti
si possano espandere.
Fino ad arrivare al pensiero creativo,
intuitivo, al pensiero causale.
La causa e l'effetto sono molto diversi
dalla correlazione tra due elementi.
Vi faccio un esempio molto semplice:
se uno osservasse semplicemente
due fenomeni per 365 giorni l'anno,
il sorgere del sole e il canto del gallo,
e ogni giorno questi due eventi
accadono nello stesso momento,
con il pensiero di associazione,
puramente di associazione,
noi potremmo dire che il sole sorge
perché il gallo canta.
Ma noi sappiamo che non è così:
non vi sto a parlare del sistema solare.
Quindi questi sono problemi
molto complessi,
attraverso i quali noi cerchiamo
di spiegare il mondo
che è pieno di incongruenze,
non è sempre così lineare.
E quindi, le macchine prenderanno
il sopravvento sull'uomo?
Sarà possibile che una macchina
possa capire cosa sto pensando,
cosa sto provando, le mie emozioni?
Ecco, io penso di no.
Penso che noi abbiamo
una responsabilità molto grossa,
cioè quella di non dimenticarci
la complessità del nostro pensiero
e come questo debba essere utilizzato
grazie all'Intelligenza Artificiale,
che dovrebbe semplificare
dei processi complessi per noi
[quando affrontiamo] il mondo.
E quindi mi piace parlare
della responsabilità etica:
dietro ogni algoritmo e ogni scelta
di applicazione dell'IA
c'è la capacità cognitiva dell'uomo,
il pensiero critico.
E quindi un uomo o una donna
che devono prendere delle decisioni etiche
e risolvere dei problemi.
E allora ritornando
a questo, alla mia storia,
se io solo avessi avuto la possibilità,
quando ho iniziato
a studiare neuroscienze,
di capire velocemente dove avrei
potuto impiegare le mie competenze,
volendo lasciare la ricerca,
e avessi avuto un aiuto dall'alto
sarebbe stato fantastico,
non ci avrei messo tre anni.
E invece ci ho messo
abbastanza, per capirlo.
E mi è capitata questa cosa meravigliosa:
un progetto che ho fatto l'anno scorso
con la scuola di Business
del Politecnico di Milano,
che si è fatta questa domanda:
"Che ruolo ha oggi l'università?"
I contenuti li possiamo trovare ovunque,
possiamo da soli accedere
a tantissima conoscenza;
e allora qual è il ruolo dell'università?
Quello di selezionare, forse,
questa complessità?
Il paradosso della scelta:
oddio, dove devo andare?
Cosa devo cercare?
E quindi abbiamo costruito
una piattaforma di continuous learning,
in cui l'Intelligenza Artificiale
aiuta l'uomo a imparare meglio,
filtra questa complessità
e restituisce una
raccomandazione di contenuti
che è stata disegnata
sul gap di competenza di ogni individuo.
Quindi ognuno, ogni singolo utente
di questa piattaforma
avrà dei contenuti raccomandati
basati su ciò che lui deve colmare,
in termini di competenza,
rispetto a degli obbiettivi professionali.
Quindi questo è come il machine learning,
quindi la macchina che impara,
aiuta l'utente a imparare sé stesso.
E quindi concludo
con uno dei miei preferiti,
cioè Charles Darwin,
che dice che "L'essere che sopravvive
non è quello più forte,
o quello più intelligente,
ma è quello che si sa
adattare meglio al mondo".
E quindi, secondo me,
l'IA deve essere vista
come uno strumento potenziante
della nostra intelligenza.
Non possiamo ritrarci dalla responsabilità
di prendere delle decisioni
e di risolvere dei problemi complessi
con il nostro stesso intelletto;
ma l'IA deve essere quello strumento
che facilita questo percorso,
che ci fa fare ancora più domande sensate
e che possa risolvere
dei problemi eticamente giusti.
E quindi ribadisco
la responsabilità che abbiamo
nel costruire questi strumenti
e anche nel fruirli
per rendere il mondo migliore.
(Applausi)